how's it going everybody so we recently
got a look at some unused concept art
from Avengers infinity war there will
probably be more that come out but right
now we have a new look at spider-man a
new look at Captain America and a few
different looks for Thor also if you're
new to my channel I'm giving away some
copies of Infinity Ward Deadpool 2 and
ant-man and the wasp as well as some
special edition posters if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so here's the deal about these
unused concept art photos from Avengers
infinity war just because they were not
used in infinity war does not mean that
they may not be used in Avengers for
Marvel sort of looks at Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 as sort of
the same movie broken up into two
different parts if you recall when they
announced infinity war and Avengers 4 it
was originally just infinity War part 1
and part 2 so for some of these there's
still a chance that we could see them in
Avengers 4 however with spider-man this
red and gold iron spider suit I do not
think we'll see this in Avengers 4 what
this is is a comic accurate iron spider
suit in the MCU they added a lot more
blue to the suit but in the comics it's
mainly red and gold much like you see
here and spider-man is kind of dust
right now so I don't think we'll see it
but you never know
same with Captain America what we have
here is basically the same Captain
America that we saw in Infinity Ward the
only difference is his hair and this
concept art he has short hair in the
movie he has long hair no star on the
chest just like an infinity war and what
we really have here is nomad Captain
America this is pretty accurate to what
we saw an infinity war with the
exception of his chest and his hair but
besides that it's pretty accurate and I
think we all think that an Avengers for
Captain America will actually pick up
the mantle of Captain America again and
with some leaked Avengers for concept
art we've even seen him wearing his
scale armor with the star on his chest
then we actually have four photos of
Thor and right off the bat it seems like
two of these photos were drawing
inspiration from the unworthy Thor
comics the way that Thor is wearing his
cape and these two
those looks exactly like how he wears it
in the unworthy Thor maybe after the
snap Thor feels kind of guilty for not
going for the head and then will
somewhat get a version of the unworthy
Thor in Avengers for this next photo is
pretty much how Thor looked in infinity
war before he got Stormbreaker
it's almost identical to how he looked
in the first half of the movie in fact I
actually think they used this concept
art photo for the movie this next photo
though is really awesome because it
almost looks like a different variation
of room King Thor it's similar to how
Thor looks in infinity war after he got
Stormbreaker with the exception of his
chest piece an infinity war after he
gets Stormbreaker his chest piece
resembles that of ultimate Thor from the
comics in this photo he doesn't have the
six circles and he has a lot of gold in
his chest piece this could possibly be a
way to try and work in a different
version of room King Thor even though
some people think that room King Thor is
too powerful to introduce into the MCU
the Avengers are going to need someone
that powerful if they're going to try
and defeat Thanos and possibly take on a
second villain that's an even bigger
threat than Thanos so that's it for this
new concept art that we received let me
know what you all think and let me know
if you think we'll see any sort of
variation of these Thor's and Avengers
for let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]